je suis venu pour être le dernier vice
roi des indes et je compte exercer je
roule avec la plus grande fierté qu'ils
allaient rendre un pays à son peuple je
ne vois pas où est le mal
vous êtes l'avenir nous vous voulez dire
faisant tout pour ne pas gâcher cet
avenir vous croyez que les indiens sont
prêts à gérer leur propre fonction
publique on a été à bonne école
je vais réunir les dirigeants et les
maharadjahs et bien que quelles que
soient leurs différences il est certain
que tous les indiens ont un point comme
lesquels ils ont hâte qu'on fiche le
camp
300 millions d'hindous et de sic veulent
une inde unis les 100 millions de
musulmans sont contre
leur propre pays le pakistan les
musulmans ne veulent pas souffrir de
discriminations comme les noirs des
états unis d'amérique vous imaginez
vraiment l'inde divisé en deux parties
vous avez tout fait pour attiser la
haine entre nos différentes communautés
cela a toujours été votre politique
diviser pour mieux régner
nous sommes tous des frères avec une
seule arme
[Musique]
lisez pour des raisons religieuses
et contre la volonté de dieu l'inde est
un de l'aviron
[Musique]
vous avez abusé de moi et de ma famille
il faut que vous trancher dans le vif
c'est une hache couverte de sang qui
brise la vie des gens nous sommes venus
rendre sa liberté à servir
pas le mettre en pièces